scary movie 5 looks so [ __ ] stupid I
cannot believe I'm gonna actually go
watch this movie it looks god-awful
remember that movie the haunted house
with Marlon Wayans well it looks better
than that but that movie has like a
negative seven percent on rotten
tomatoes so what the [ __ ] are we really
comparing this to I remember the first
scary movie was a decent spoof flick
that had a hard R rating now there's
this pg-13 crap with the same repetitive
[ __ ] jokes oh haha ashley tisdale
hit the obviously fake baby against the
wall who can old pots and pans falling
on simon rex Charlie Sheen's getting
into the crotch and let's not forget a
black man stealing Wow original the one
thing I enjoyed throughout this
franchise was the lovely Anna Faris but
now she's not in it anymore and her
missing presence can really be felt it's
gotten to the point or by now these
filmmakers should have said to
themselves we should stop repeating
ourselves with the same damn shitty
slapstick comedy but no they're stupid
they just can't take a [ __ ] hint it's
just another dumb spoof comedy we're all
its best moments are in the trailer and
if this trailer is their best moments oh
god damnation is near I'm very confident
when I say scary movie 5 will get it
wrong
you
alright guys tell me your points below
about what you think about the upcoming
movie scary movie 5 and if you liked the
video like the video and if you want to
see more reviews go ahead and subscribe
to my channel